quick announcement for everyone
i've been told that lines live streaming
begins at probably at nine o'clock
so
whatever conversations you're having
will be heard
by
uh whoever's watching the live stream
we'll start the meeting officially in
[Music]
instructions
good morning everyone i'm going to open
and officially convene
this meeting of the science technology
and energy committee our first session
of the 2022
legislative year
and i'm going to
uh now that i've called this meeting to
order my first order of business
is to
discuss what otherwise might become the
element in the room if i don't mention
it
those of you who know me will detect
that i have a frog in my throat
i do have a cold
however i have had two negative covid
tests in the past 36 hours
and four negative coveted tests in the
past week
i will be wearing a mask when i'm not
talking in front of the microphone
i will not wear a mask when i'm talking
here i will not wear a mask
if you need to approach me to discuss
something please give me a second to put
my mask on before you get too close
i'm
very concerned
and sensitive to the need for everyone's
health and safety to be protected and i
will do everything i can to do that
okay
so with that uh
out of the way
let's uh
begin our meeting by all rising for the
pledge of allegiance
led by the doyen of our committee
the first uh item on the agenda is a
quick presentation
on the
live stream
situation here in the room and all the
equipment in the room i've asked kristen
grant our committee researcher to give
us a quick
uh one or two minute overview of the
live streaming session you'll notice
that there are microphones there are
speakers and there are cameras in this
room
and kristin will give us a quick
overview and then you can ask christian
questions if you have any
so
okay as soon as
thank you
okay i
first of all as uh chairman bose
mentioned the stream has started we
don't have to do anything to make that
happen
the guys you know i'm by myself i can do
this um
the
team up in
media
they're starting the stream remotely and
they're going to start it you know
whenever the meeting is supposed to
convene
if there's a problem
they'll hopefully handle it if we know
of a problem i'll try to let them know
um if you decide to caucus i'll try to
let them know so they can cut the feed
because nobody needs to watch that
they
because it's a service that we're
providing if the feed goes down the
meeting can continue
there's no need to stop it um
the
otherwise there's it's really just
because people can still come into the
room so that's basically what we're
being told it's just it's
it's a service so if
it crashes
it's unfortunate but it's not going to
cause us any
the microphones are not only to get the
feed to the stream
audio feed to the stream but also for
amplification because of the um
what we call the r2d2s that are cleaning
the air make it hard to hear anybody's
and if we're speaking with masks on
that's even more of a potential issue
the microphones are set or should be set
i asked them last night
to allow up to four
people
to be live at once
[Music]
and by that i mean
if
four
people try to turn on their mics
they should be i'll be allowed to speak
but if a fifth person turns on their mic
their
light will be a blinking green
and
they will be next in the queue but they
won't be amplified until somebody turns
off their mic
so it's critical for amplification
and for the feed that when you're done
speaking
you push the button and turn off your
mic so
it's been sort of um
it's like when we were remote when you
were remote i wasn't here yet when one
was remote and you wanted to be on mute
all the time so that the random sounds
of your household didn't come through
accidentally same thing here um except
it's only one at a time and chairman
votes can mute us all
with the button you have two buttons
and you may already know this i'm not
sure you have two buttons uh one
is obviously the guy talking that's to
speak um the other i believe can shut
everybody off
so
yeah see if that works
um i don't remember what the
picture is
there's one with a face
okay i'll keep talking and we'll see
what happens if you can uh can you mute
me
now i know which one turns you off
exactly yeah exactly so that's that's
fun thank you yeah
so um you'll see it's kind of
counterintuitive to me
but red means you're all set
green means you're not going to be
amplified green and blinking means
you're next but you're still not going
to be amplified i don't know if anybody
wants to like do you want two more
people want to turn them on
so you mick williams could speak and
um
okay so representative sansitch would be
how many do we have so we have four here
and now
representative plett turned his off so
now you're live representative sausage
so
when it's red we're live is that when
it's red you're live
and uh representative votes you asked
about the sensitivity and i'm not sure
how to exactly measure that but
the um
uh john upstairs said
um
pretty much just
assume that people can hear you
you know when you're talking um but also
be as close as necessary um so basically
turn off your mic if
you don't want people to hear what
could you go over um to turn it off
again absolutely
sorry
i did it to demonstrate but i didn't say
what i was doing
if it's white it's off correct
yep so push the same button to turn it
on and to turn it off yep
okay kristin am i also detecting that
there is a speaker built into the base
of this microphone i think so
and you're also hearing
well these monitors are pointing this
way but yes there's can you hear
yourselves because i'm right next to the
monitor so i can't tell where i'm
hearing this from but are you hearing
yourself and me
from in front of you
that must be yeah i think that's what
that is yeah
yeah sorry okay well kristen thank you
that was a
a better uh uh overview than i was
actually expecting
thanks
any other questions just let me know
yeah does anybody have a question for
for kristin about the live streams
i have a question okay what if one of
our members gets a text from one of
their constituents and the text says
i can't hear the live stream or i can't
see it or something
what recourse do we have
to give them to
notify
the media people that there's a problem
i don't know if they have a way to
connect directly with them so i would
say if if i'm here let me know and i'll
tell media or
um
i should be here or if i'm not here i'll
be around you know but you can contact
me or contact
committee services and we'll let them
know
if there is a direct contact that i can
get
i'll give that to all of you so i'll
that'll be one of the things i follow up
on to find out
great thank you
okay any additional questions for
kristen
did i hear someone call my name
no no
okay
thank you kristen and does everybody
have their
oh you just got yours their name tags uh
their name plates and their folders
oh yes we're still waiting for yours
sorry
okay thank you
thank you kristen okay
so the next item on my agenda was just a
quick
discussion of
microphone etiquette
and what i wanted to remind everybody
was that when you're speaking
and then you finish speaking you should
turn your microphone off
if you don't get in the habit of doing
that one of these days you're going to
forget to turn it off and then you're
going to say something
that maybe
you don't want the rest of the world to
hear so
try to get in the habit of turning your
micro microphone off as soon as you're
done speaking
and of course the other part of that is
be extremely careful that
whatever you say
might be picked up by the live streaming
uh equipment in this room so
if it's not something you want repeated
if it's not something you want to see in
print
be careful
okay
uh we don't have very good attendance so
far this morning which is a bit
disappointing but
uh it is an extremely cold day and and
travel is probably a little difficult
for some people
but what i would like to do next since
it's been a long time since we've gotten
together
in the same room
i would like to
[Music]
initiate committee reintroductions so
i'd like to go around the room and have
every person
re-introduce themselves please tell us
your name what district you represent
and if you choose to it's it's optional
but if you choose to you can say
something about
why you're here what you hope to
accomplish
so
let's start with representative mann one
of the senior members of our committee
back in the back left of the room from
my point of view
so representative mann get us going
okay well i'm representative man
john mann from
alstead new hampshire which is where i
live and i represent
cheshire county district two
and uh
i guess i'm interested in uh
i'm representative partial from cheshire
district 10 proudly serving marlboro and
troy new hampshire
and uh
i'm honored in doing so in order to
serve the best is my constituents uh
whatever they made even
representative partial thank you uh i
lived in troy when i went to high school
so
you're probably representing people that
i know there there's some good people
there i'm glad representative bernardi
yes uh representative jd bernardi
rockingham 16 which is southampton east
kingston and kensington
my name is representative lex berezni i
represent grafton district 9 which
includes grafton ashland
bristol
and
bridgewater and
i'm here representing my constituents
uh representative brezhne you might want
to move your mic just a little bit
closer
it did pick you up but
you might be a little
hard to hear that far away
representative floggie
good morning i'm tom ploucher
beldnap one i represent the citizens and
residents
of
new hampton and center harbor i'm from
yes good morning i'm peter somsich
i represent rockingham county district
27 portsmouth ward 3.
and
i think as with the science background
i've always been attracted to various
energy related issues so
i'm glad to be here and be of service to
thank you peter just to repeat i'm
representative michael vose i represent
rockingham district nine the town of
epping
and this is my fourth term in the
legislature and all four terms i've
served on this committee proudly served
i'm rep shouting in this thing
i'm representative fred platt
from goffstown new hampshire uh my life
has been in the utilities industry 23
years with public service new hampshire
then i went from there to a manufacturer
to every research entity uh to a
computer consulting outfit from
uk logica
and with some other steps the last 10
years of my working career was as a
consumer advocate for the mass attorney
i'm representative janine notter i'm
from the town of merrimack i'm the house
majority whip
our late speaker dick hinch placed me on
this committee four terms ago i didn't
know why at the time but i've since
learned that i really am fascinated with
energy
i'm representative nick white i'm from
merrimack district 20. that's chichester
and pembroke and i have primarily a
technology background telecommunications
wireless technology
i'm representative john lewicki i
represent hillsborough 26 which is the
towns of brookline and mason my
background is in
technology i've worked a lot of startups
in new hampshire and massachusetts and
also with some bigger companies uh over
time but i've moved around a lot and
put computer microprocessors in a lot of
good morning welcome to concord and you
are in my district i'm representative
rebecca mcwilliams and um i serve the
west side of concord including downtown
so happy to host you
my background is i'm both an architect
and an attorney
i'm very interested in construction
energy efficiency and building envelope
solutions
i'm also here to represent my kids i
have four-year-old twins and a
one-year-old so i'm here looking to the
future and seeing what i can do to make
new hampshire better for our next
generation
thank you are there any other committee
members that did not speak oh
representative callie pitts the doyan of
the committee i'm sorry
representative callie pitts i represent
portsmouth wards one two four and five
i've been on the committee for 25 years
i'm still learning
i hope to learn more
i hope to do more
and i hope to bring back some
collegiality to the community
and to the committee and i i wish to
welcome
you get stuck with me and you'll find
out that i'm a little bit of a pain but
i kind of know what i'm talking about
thank you
mr chairman i took the opportunity to do
the attendance with that
it's all done excellent thank you mr
clerk
fred didn't mention when he introduced
himself that he serves as the committee
clerk
representative doug thomas who's the
vice chair of the committee will be here
probably within the hour he had
his wife had a doctor's appointment that
he had to take her to this morning but
he will be here
and i trust that
other members of the committee such as
representatives mcgee and oxenam who
will be presenting our first bill in six
minutes will be here soon as well
and john i want to apologize to you john
lewicky representative wiki i should
have welcomed you to the committee right
at the very first thing i forgot to do
that i apologize but i want to say now
welcome to stne we're glad to have you
on board thank you mr chairman no
okay
next item on my agenda is a just a quick
uh outline of what today's agenda is
we have five public hearings today
two this morning and we'll take a lunch
break at around 11 30ish whenever the
second public hearing finishes
and then at one o'clock we have another
one
one two and three so we'll have three
this afternoon that's a total of five
public hearings today
four of those bills the last four
are all early bills meaning that they
have to be done by the 17th of february
so
that's one of the reasons we're hearing
them today to get those public hearings
done so that
we'll be in a position to pass judgment
on those bills
sooner rather than later there is a
fifth
early bill that the committee needs to
hear and it will be the first bill that
we hear
there will be no executive sessions
today
so
no one has to be concerned
about a lack of attendance uh at our
now going forward
i've already scheduled
although most of you probably haven't
seen it yet because i don't think carrie
morris our committee admin has published
the schedule yet i've already scheduled
the remaining bills
for the committee
we will have
four additional meetings
just like today's
where five public hearings are held on
each day
so the dates are
the 18th of january the 25th of january
the 1st of february
and the 8th of february
so you will see a notice
for each of those sessions from
ms morris later today
and
i decided to schedule all of those
public hearings ahead of time
as a courtesy to the bill sponsors so
that they could
plan for when they have to be here to
introduce their bill
and also as a courtesy to the members of
the committee so that you can all plan
your activity
around
those public hearings if you need to be
out on one of those days for
whatever reason at least you'll
you'll know
when the bill is being heard so you can
make arrangements to find out about it
if you if you can't be here for the
now because we finish our public
hearings on february 8th
we'll be able to proceed proceed to
subcommittee
meetings and or executive sessions
starting on february as early as
february 14th
you've all noticed that we're in a
different room this year than we have
been in past years
that accommodation was made
because the two committees that
ordinarily share this room both had a
heavy bill load
whereas the two committees that share
our
our previous room 302 304 had relatively
light legislative loads
so by swapping
one of the heavy load committees with
one of the light load committees it'll
make scheduling this room easier
we share this room with election law
i've worked out with representative
barbara griffin who is the chair of
election law that we can have this room
on mondays and
tuesdays and election law will have it
on wednesday thursday and friday
so
we could start having either
subcommittee or executive session
meetings as early as february 14th which
would be the monday
we won't make a decision about that
until after we have our our final public
hearings it could either be on monday
the 14th or tuesday the 15th
that we have executive sessions on the
early bills because they have to be done
so that's our agenda for the next four
weeks uh representative callie pitts
mr chair
for the public can they still uh sign in
on their preference on the bill like we
have the blue sheets here can they do
that remotely
in other words if i'm in favor of a bill
and i'm at home
can i still
sign in to that bill at home
that's an excellent question
representative and i do not know the
answer i i'm sorry that i don't i can't
answer that i think you can do it but i
mean yes it's the same process it is
yeah okay same process as last year
apparently
okay follow-up would it be possible to
just briefly
describe that process so anybody
listening at home could do that if they
wish
um
it's been a long time since i've done it
but as i recall
you click on a link
on the general court website
you
specify the name of the committee
then you
spec pick a bill
and then you just follow the screen
prompts to
allow you to
record
your opinion about the bill
thank you very much
anybody else
okay good i have a comment
uh representative mcwilliams thank you
i just wanted to say that it's also
possible to email the entire committee
at the house science technology and
can you hear me now
it's possible to email the entire
committee i believe the email address is
house science technology and energy all
one word
at
oh boy
leg
dot
n a dot state dot h dot
u s
leg state nh u s with a period in
between each one of those you can find
that on the website as well but you can
reach us via email to all the members of
the committee
thank you representative good point
that's the way we've always
we've always been able to
communicate with the committee via that
method
wow representative mcgee you just made
it
thank you for uh for being here
so mr chairman
yes representative zamcic can i just
inquire about executive sessions um am i
assuming that there won't be any until
after
that's likely the case um
there may be an extraordinary
circumstance that requires us to have
one sooner but
my plan right now is to wait until after
the only reason i'm asking uh right now
is that
if for some situations we need a
substitute before because they have to
come in here in person
it would be good to get a heads up on
that
absolutely absolutely agreed
okay before we start our first public
hearing
i just want to go over some rules and
logistics for the operation of the
committee those of you who want to speak
on a given bill at its public hearing
must submit a pink
card
such as the one representative plett
is holding a loft
they are on the back table
back there
you fill one out and either bring it up
to representative pled or pass it up
along the table to representative platt
you can't speak unless you submit a pink
card
depending on the number of people who
sign up to speak on a given bill we're
going to limit
we're also going to limit questions from
members of the committee to two
questions per member
and i'd remind members
that we're here to gather information in
public hearings
that means
ask questions
do not make speeches
you're not here to debate
the people testifying you're not here to
debate each other
we're here to gather information
that we can use later
to deliberate and make decisions about
these bills
there's plenty of time for debate in
sub-committee meetings and or executive
sessions
so be very careful and be very sensitive
to the fact
that you just need to ask questions and
if you can make your questions as
succinct and precise as possible you'll
probably get a better answer if you ask
a long rambling question
the answer you get may not
be particularly useful so
think about that as you put together
your your questions
so representative mcgee welcome
um we had a little committee
introduction uh earlier so when you sit
down to introduce your bill if you would
like you could tell us who you are what
district you represent and
an optional brief comment about
uh
your service on the committee
and uh
so
at 9
30 34
i believe it is
no it's actually 9 30. that clock is
fast
uh i'm going to open the public hearing
relative to the multi-use energy data
flat platform
and i'm
very pleased to
have the bill be introduced by a
long-time member of this committee
the honorable representative kat mcgee
take it away thank you mr chairman and
uh
good morning everyone
uh yes my name is uh representative cat
mcgee and i'm from hillsborough 27 which
is hollis
uh
and i've been on the committee this is
my second term
and in my first term i had the good
fortune to help pass a bill that came to
us from the senate for
the review of whether the state of new
hampshire should have an energy
data platform that would allow us to be
able to see
use
and manage our energy data
so a bit of an esoteric project but
my background is in software engineering
program management so it was actually
it's a software project and so
i uh i stayed with
the project
i was invited by the consumer advocate
to intervene on the docket at the public
utilities commission and so i followed
it over there
and as the pandemic hit in the first
year we went online with our technical
sessions and about 34 interveners
started working on discussing all of the
aspects of the statewide energy data
platform
that were
defined in
the statute
when the bill was passed and signed into
law
and one of those aspects was privacy and
security which was of course a big
concern for the utilities
they have an obligation
to protect
consumers energy data
and so the original statute
rsa
78 colon 51
assigned the determination of the data
privacy and security to the public
utilities commission process
and that bill was signed into law in
and the
adjudicative proceeding went forward
with all of the stakeholders including
all of the utilities
um henceforth in 2020
um and we all went forward with a
unanimous settlement agreement
to the two then commissioners uh this
past spring
so
what happened was
when there was a decision to add a
department of energy
which
i think is a great idea
the statute
in hb2 that was written the 80 pages
that was delivered to define the
the practices of the department of
energy along with how it would interact
with the public utilities commission
it ended up giving
that requirement for the data platform
to the department of energy
but it so the new statute which came
under rsa 378-52
is now in conflict with the existing
original
statutory language
and the efforts to define
those technical pieces that's already
already occurred
at the public utilities commission with
all of the utilities
so we had all the technical expertise
and we
undertook what we were told to do based
on the original rsa
uh so this
this is sort of a reinvent the wheel
requirement that was put into language
i guess that's that's it
okay thank you um representative
mcgee
does this change
apply to rule-making
is that why it's necessary to make this
change
no it's actually it's the technical
aspect of
determining the standards around how
security and privacy will be
administered
so that had to be defined and that was
one of the things that they wanted in
the original language to make sure that
it was
fully vetted
so yeah it doesn't have anything to do
with rulemaking
okay so the definition
exists where
if not in rules
uh i think
i think actually the consumer advocate
who is here to speak as well may be more
familiar with that piece than i am i
don't have that in front of me um
okay thank you sure um representative
knotter you have a question yes thank
you mr chairman and thank you for taking
the question and you said you were for
follow up mr
chairman follow up
um
you also said it was an addition but
wasn't it
really a combination of other agencies
and
departments to create one
[Music]
i'm not sure i understand the question
the department of energy was a
combination of other
agencies to create one rather than
several different
um
groups
i don't understand
i think the department of energy is
devoted to energy and we had hoped that
there would be such an agency
to play point on questions around energy
policy so that we'd have somebody to
consult with
um because it's a you know it's a big
sector of the economy and i know when
the data platform went in and i was
trying to help shepherd that i was
concerned with the technical piece of
the project not being lost because most
of the people that were involved in
trying to pass it were non-technical but
one of the things that i argued was it
has no home
in the state right there's nobody to own
it and uh you know if there's going to
be a platform
that is statewide then somebody at the
state needs to understand it and be able
to have you know decision making
capability on that so um yeah so i had
at the time
mentioned the fact that it would be
really nice if we had a department of
energy to go to for decisions around
that
um
so i'm not sure if i answered your
question because i still don't
understand you're saying a bunch of
agencies
yeah well
the public utilities commission is a
is a regulatory body that's the
distinction really that's made between
them and the agencies which fall under
the executive branch
and so
i think
when i read through the 80 pages in hb2
that defined the department of energy
um you know one of the things that was
told to us when we saw those
presentations was there's going to be a
bright red line between the regulatory
agency
and you know the
the department of energy
and so i would still maintain that
they're two different animals that it's
it's not really a combination of those
two agencies
it's that the public utilities
commission budget is now going to come
under the department of energy so
they'll be administered from within the
department of of energy
but it wasn't really i don't think it
was intended to be a full merging
of their duties because they're separate
follow-up mr speaker
uh no i'm sorry we're restricting
questions to two per member thank you
representative
any other questions for uh
representative mcgee representative mick
williams
thank you mr chair um representative
mcgee can you just speak a little bit
further to
uh the language in this bill that says
there's going to be a
qualification and registration process
um can you tell me who's setting that up
how is that administered i think the
language before that uh oh thank you for
your question representative mick
williams
um i think the language before that
qualifies a third party and
um the
15 months of
conversations that we had around how
this platform would go forward if in
fact it's approved after there's an rfp
um
was that
it would likely be outsourced rather
than have the technical resources within
the utilities
building it so we would be giving them
you know
highly defined um
requirements which we we produced during
that process together
and uh the third party vendor would then
have to
prove and vet um the level of standard
that we've defined in terms of security
and privacy
of the utility data not just the utility
data but that's pretty much the prime
sources utilities
thank you representative sure
thank you uh representative platt
thank you for the opportunity
um you are choosing
to change
with this bill
378-522 to uh from the department of
energy to commission to resolve a
conflict the other way you could have
resolved the conflict is to take where
the conflict occurs and change that to
the department of energy so it's
entirely in the department of energy
why did you choose the puc rather than
the department of energy
well
the way i described in the testimony i
wrote which i didn't read is that it's a
question of reinventing the wheel
because the case has already the the
adjudicative docket
right where all of the stakeholders were
working towards the answers to the
solution you know coming up with
solutions
it's already been done so the folks at
the department of energy don't have the
benefit of any of those 15 months worth
of discussions with the technical people
from the utilities
and so the conversations around what has
to be done
what this is doing is it it took the
language from the original statute and
just switched it over and said somebody
else needs to do it
but it didn't take into account the two
and a half years in between where
somebody was already doing that
so it doesn't make sense to put it the
other way
because um the original statute is the
one that's already been followed
so we don't we don't need an exploration
for how security and privacy
should go forward because the utilities
have already
provided that information
representative samsic
thank you mr chairman and thank you
representative mcgee um
i just want to
verify that i heard
your presentation correctly you were
talking about a need for someone to to
own this
platform and have a home
for the platform
do i understand correctly that
that ownership and that home would be
the puc
no is it the department of energy
well and your bill here as stated here
talks about this
secure environment and privacy standards
established by the commission so does
one agency establish the privacy
requirements and the other one owns it
or the same entity owns it and
that gives it a home no thank you for
the question uh representative samsich
it's a good question i think
um the platform itself if it ends up
going forward
would likely be under the under the
purview of the department of energy i
think that would be where the oversight
would come from the definition of
getting us to the point where we had
requirements to send out for an rfp that
was the complicated part was hashing
through
what are we building what will it do
what are the benefits and until we had
all of that definition we couldn't
really ask somebody to price it because
it's a software project so they have to
tell you how much it'll cost to build
and um i'll just say this so that you
guys can be informed of this because it
matters
the utilities agreed with us that the
correct architecture for the project was
an api of apis and what that means is
that there would be a processing unit
that would be in between
the data that they hold and the data
that gets aggregated and goes out to the
person who's making a query of the
system
so basically it's a very nimble agile
system and it's not really expensive to
build the architecture that way
so we did a lot of the pre-work in order
to save the state money there was no
cost really to that adjudicative
proceeding
and so
the adjudicative proceeding
forced all of the stakeholders to come
together at their own expense
and try and get us to
the starting point and so what we're
saying is that language
that
made the charge of figuring out how
privacy and security should be done
still needs to remain consistent that it
was part of the adjudicative proceeding
and is not something that the doe has to
reinvent now
we just don't want it to say cause then
because then somebody will feel they
have to do something because it's in law
right so it's just they're inconsistent
follow up
thank you mr chairman just one follow-up
um
can you again state for us uh what
actually the purpose and the goal is of
having a energy data platform sure
um
i don't know if anybody's heard but you
know data's kind of king right now
and um a lot of the sort of downstream
management of energy in the future
especially
with all the different types of energy
sources there are now
will be governed by who can see the full
picture of what's happening with energy
we like to say we have a saying that we
would use which is you can't manage what
you can't measure
and so the energy data platform is to
move the state forward so that we can
have that snapshot and be able to
aggregate data in a way that makes sense
so that we can look at
for example community power you know if
if folks
who are doing something together want to
be able to see a picture of what they're
doing they can't really get that now
it's very very cumbersome and clunky and
you have to
go back to the well with the utilities
again and again to try and get your own
data so we're really just trying to open
that up so that
the data can be used in order to make
improvements and again
that doesn't cost anything but it will
representative brezhney
thank you mr chairman and thank you
representative mcgee for taking my
question
if this bill doesn't pass
in the department of energy
will they be recreating all of the same
information and if they do that are they
able to reuse
what was produced by the commission
thank you
sure
um i think the point of the
language in the bill which actually came
from the consumer advocate
um
in our discussion that there was an
inconsistency in what was in you know
what was in statute uh by the passing of
this section of the bill
i think the
department of energy
as it is right now doesn't have the kind
of proceeding that we pursued over at
the puc the puc is kind of uniquely
set up to have to host these kinds of
meetings
um
in order and we had
we had several maybe eight or so
eight hour technical sessions
you know and that's just not something
the doe would likely undertake
so i guess to answer your question
if it goes into law this way there will
be confusion because the doe will feel
as though it has a requirement to do
something to achieve this
could they use the information that's
already been provided
um i
i don't know if i can i don't know if i
can answer that um i mean it would make
sense to
um
but i just think we we're just trying to
clear up the confusion in the statute
that it's not consistent with itself
that there's two existing statues that
say two different things and i just
wanted you to know the background of the
fact that
the first statute
created a process where we where we
responded to what we were told to do
so it isn't necessary to say now the doe
has to tell us what to do
they don't they don't really have to do
that
and i'm not sure they have the
the people to do it either because it
was they were technical you know
security
considerations
i have a question as well
we received written testimony that says
that
on may 5th
the parties went before the commission
to present a settlement agreement
and so far the commission has failed to
issue an order in the in the docket
does this change affect that settlement
agreement does it affect the docket
what
impact will making this change have on
what's going forward as of
today uh it shouldn't have any because
because the
the new language for the new statute
came from hb2
and
affects the platform which was
implemented back in 2019 in terms of
moving forward with the adjudicative
proceeding so it shouldn't have
any effect if we
move this in to to clarify the
information
it is kind of an issue that the
the puc hasn't come up with a decision
since cinco de mayo but um which was a
very happy day for all of us
um never seen such kumbaya
with everybody involved
however i mean i think there's been a
pattern over there of um
delay and also you know there's been a
bit of upheaval there's been changes in
personnel and they haven't had full
complement so
i think regardless of what is going on
with the public utilities commission and
their decision
the
the extent of the
the detailed requirements that have been
developed we developed user stories
which are the more sophisticated level
and also had many many discussions with
the technical people and security people
of the utilities
so
i
you know i
no matter which way it goes at the
public utilities commission that work
has already been done that's the way i
would say it
great thank you for clarifying that
point
representative callie pitts
thank you for taking my question um
i was concerned a little bit by this is
what we were told to do
who and where
and on this type of security information
is this personal information is this
kilowatt hour is used is this
because
kilowatt hours as i understand it is is
reported regularly
so is this personal information we're
talking about
uh the intent of the
data platform is to allow us to
aggregate data information so it's not
related to the individual customers at
all
it's the idea of being able to look at
data that you want to see combined
basically so no the the personal
information that's part of the privacy
standards and considerations that we
worked through yeah
so
i
i mean that's the people from the
utilities who have
you know frontline responsibility for
securing that data
were the people who contributed the
solutions that
i think they they understand you know
they understand both what the tool is
intended to do with energy data and also
the privacy concerns for the individual
customer that have to be protected so
all of those conversations were what we
okay again i'm going to ask who was
doing this
who told you to do this
and is this data already
in fractured form available from other
places that is a broad bracelet
um
is this available again are we going at
kilowatt hours are we going to you know
timer use
yeah and all that is is that all
available
in
the different utilities
and is this an effort to just combine
this and put it all together
it's a good question thank you for the
question representative kelly cutts
who told us to do it was the passing of
the bill so the the statute that was
passed 378 51 the original statute was
who told us what we had to do what we
had to satisfy
um so that's who told us to do it the us
would be
the the people who
joined in as interveners on the docket
uh to engage in the discussions around
solving for the things that the law told
us we needed to satisfy
um
and so that included all of the
utilities and they
were very generous in supplying
technical resources for those
conversations
um
and as far as where the data is it's
actually we had testimony on that
um that there are there are some towns
that are more
you know aggressive in trying to
either convert to cleaner energy sources
or invest in unique things getting their
energy picture means
we had testimony actually from
from someone who's engaged in that work
in hanover i believe
and
what she said was we pulled together
all of our data from the utilities
got it in a spreadsheet managed it you
know created macros did all these things
to to create the picture and then they
realized it took them six months to do
it and the next time they want to look
at it it would take them six months
again so
it can be done
but it
in an information age where you can have
you know systems do that kind of
combinations for you it just doesn't
make any sense for us to have no way of
getting the data that we're trying to
get and so we're trying to really just
advance the state's ability to look at
what's happening with energy across the
state and then you can make better
decisions from there because you then
have the information that you need
available
okay thank you representative callie
pitts remember to turn off your mic good
questions
all right any more questions for
representative mcgee
seeing none i thank you representative
for your testimony
griffin robarge who will represent the
department of energy and he's asked for
two minutes he's neutral on this build
but would like to take a few minutes to
speak about it
can you hear me okay yes all right
um good morning chairman vos and members
of the committee for the record my name
is griffin roberge and i work for the
new hampshire department of energy
uh here to testify today on house bill
um based on conversations with staff
within the department it appears this
bill is
a technical fix
um the state statute as the prime
sponsor already indicated um there was a
bill two years ago in 2019 that created
this platform
that senate bill 284 for everybody's
reference
given that the department was created
through the budget trailer bill last
year hb2
there were a number of changes
throughout statute
for the department
this appears to be
something that was changed removed the
original commission reference on line
six replaced it with the department of
energy and the bill is looking to move
it back to commission
um like i said the department kind of
believes this is a technical fix as the
puc has already commenced in uh
a proceeding on this and for the record
that's d e
19-19-7
and they've already uh i believe they
also have a settlement agreement that
was
filed with a puc in april of this of
last year in 2021
containing the section on platform
security and privacy standards
the puc
held a hearing
on the settlement agreement on may 5th
of last year however it has not
uh there hasn't been an order issued by
the puc yet um at this point at this
point the establishment of the privacy
standards is pending before the
commission in the form of settlement
agreement um i know this seems like a
technical fix but i think the department
would like to at least take a
a quick glance at the whole statute
holistically just be sure that there
aren't any other changes that need to
take place little housekeeping measures
separation of the puc in the department
of energy
in the budget they just want to make
sure that they capture all the necessary
changes that need to take place
with that i'm willing to take any
questions
on a side note i started with the
department three days ago so i might not
have answers to everything but rest
assured i will try to get you an answer
as soon as possible
thank you
uh mr roberge and my apologies for
mispronouncing your name
do not worry
representative thomas is recognized for
a question
uh thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question this is truly a
clarification question uh
would you what year was sb 284
associated with just for my records yeah
so that is uh i believe it was
introduced in 2019 signed into law in
the same year
thank you very much appreciate it
representative bernardi is recognized
for a question
thank you mr chairman
mr robert uh if this change is not made
does the doe have the ability to use the
information that's already been
set into motion by the puc and go
representative there's a very good
question i would love to get back to you
on that one um i will certainly follow
up with you as soon as possible on that
one
uh representative platt has recognized
her question yes thank you mr chairman
mr robarus you said you want to take a
holistic look at the statutes to make
sure that nothing's missed missing sure
that's great
when yeah so we we have an exact coming
up no no and i understand i i understand
from representative uh or chairman
votes's comments say that there isn't
going to be an exec session today um but
yeah that's my understanding but um
certainly like to get back to the
committee as soon as possible i don't
want to necessarily give a timeline or
over promise anything
but obviously we want to get you guys an
answer sooner rather than later
representative notre is recognized thank
you mr chairman and thank you for taking
the question
being the new kid on the block did you
know that the department of energy was a
combination of the office of strategic
initiatives and the public utilities
commission and the idea for that
combining came from the governor's
office yes i do understand that and just
to answer a little bit of your question
of the prime sponsor earlier i believe
the puc is administratively attached to
the
department of energy but
doesn't get involved with well obviously
participates in various dockets and that
type of thing but
doesn't have like a leadership role in
the puc or anything like that i should
say
representative loki is wrecking thank
you mr chairman and uh this is not just
to uh mr roberts but uh to all of the
people testifying and providing
clarification could you please send all
of those to all of the members of the
committee and please try to reference
the rsa so that we can do our homework
that was that was my intention to send
okay representative samsuch is
recognized uh thank you mr chairman and
thank you mr robert you just answered a
question from one of my committee
members here
who asked
whether the
department of energy could
even without this change
use that data to make changes that are
needed
i would like to
add on to that request to say
can you tell us what is the most
effective way of making those changes
there's always a work around everything
but it might be the efficient way of
doing it
thank you
any further questions for
yes representative razny
thank you representative rose chairman
rose
my question is is there somebody already
in charge of running this project or
implementing this system and
would they be knowledgeable about
um all of these issues in the bill
um like i uh thank you for the question
representative as i mentioned there is
an active proceeding before the puc and
there are a number of parties involved
in that including the puc
um i
uh and the utilities as well
i'm sure there might be others to speak
uh after me in terms of where the
proceeding currently stands i as i
mentioned you know um there's a hearing
on the settlement agreement but it has
not yet issued and the puc has not yet
issued an order um can certainly try to
get you
a stats update as to you know
how that proceeding has been going and
provide you a link to the docket as well
okay
any additional
comments or questions i should say for
mr roberge i have a comment
uh the department of energy deserves
congratulations for hiring mr roberge
because
in his previous role as an aide to the
senate energy and natural resources
committee
he demonstrated
a level of detail that is
that was superb and a knowledge of
industry
energy matters that was also superb so i
think the department of energy did a
good job by hiring mr roberts thank you
for testifying this morning thank you mr
chairman thank you members of the
committee
okay
we'll now turn to our
next presenter
and i'll ask
the consumer advocate don crease to come
forward and give us his testimony on
this bill and i will say good morning mr
crease it's wonderful to see you again
likewise chairman votes it's great to be
with all of you today uh my name is
donald crease i am the consumer advocate
by statute my job is to represent the
interests of residential utility
customers i wrote down what
representative kelly pitts said because
the same thing applies to me she said
you get stuck with me
but i kind of know what i'm talking
about
um
the
data platform statute originated with a
request that i made to senator fuller
clark
back in 2019 to introduce a bill to
create such a platform and the reason i
made that request is and this is
consistent with what representative
mcgee said
access to data is really important to
consumers and when i say access to data
i mean data about their usage of energy
that they are able to share with third
parties that are unregulated so not
utilities that provide consumers with
services that allow them to save money
and become more active and engaged users
of the grid without necessarily spending
a lot of time on it themselves the data
currently reposes in the back end of the
systems that utilities have
and what the platform will do is provide
a ready source or a ready go-to place
for that data and you as a consumer can
authorize a third party to access that
data and that third party pings the
platform gets the data and provides you
with services based on the data and i
agree with representative mcgee that
that is
a key element of providing benefits of
the transition to competition for
uh
electric natural gas
utility customers
back in 2019 uh this bill got to
governor sununu for his signature and it
was one of only two energy related bills
that he signed into law and did not veto
and i think that says something to all
of you or should say something to all of
you about
the importance and the
non-controversial nature of this
initiative there were questions about
ownership of the platform as i
originally drafted the bill i was going
to propose having the public utilities
commission actually operate this
platform this was before there was a
department of energy so i couldn't
suggest having the department of energy
do it
but in the preliminary discussions with
the
public utilities commission and with the
department of information technology it
was suggested to me that it would be
better to have this data platform live
in the private sector so what we did in
the statute is actually task the
utilities with developing and operating
the platform uh but the idea is that
they would be subject to some oversight
so that they don't do that in a
self-interested way so the statute told
the puc to open an adjudicative
proceeding it did that and there was a
remarkable bit of very intense
collaboration and cooperation amongst
all the stakeholders i went into that
process with a great deal of skepticism
i came out of that process really
excited i heard representative mcgee
call it a kumbaya moment it was a it was
one of it probably the most successful
effort at collaboration i've seen in the
what five years that i have been a
consumer advocate as a result of that we
entered into a
very comprehensive settlement agreement
we filed it on april 21st of 2021
as you heard the commission conducted a
hearing on may 5th of 2021
and i would say respectfully that the
settlement agreement to which there was
no opposition has
languished
at the puc since then so just yesterday
with the agreement i think of all the
major parties to the docket i sent the
commission a letter requesting an
expedited decision and i actually
offered to write their order for them
i used to write orders for the puc for a
living back when i was the general
counsel of the puc so i know how to do
it and if they need that kind of help
because they're very busy and very
resource challenged i'd be happy to
do that for them i agree with the
department of energy and mr roberge that
this is a technical fix my perspective
on the bill is that it paves the way for
uh expedited or efficient approval of
the settlement agreement by not
introducing any confusion into what the
process is from getting to where we are
to where we need to be so the reason to
do the bill is to basically allow that
settlement process to continue to go
forward the settlement does not
automatically lead to the development of
the platform what it leads to is the
creation of a platform governance
council
that will develop a request for
proposals the rfp will go out the
responses will come in we'll figure out
what this thing will cost and
that's where the rubber will hit the
road
i think that's all i have to say and of
course i'd be happy to answer questions
thank you for that
illuminating testimony i have a quick
question
before i open it up to the rest of the
committee
you stated that there is an open docket
about the settlement agreement before
the puc it's been open since
my question is do you have any
assurance that this change isn't going
to disrupt what's already seems to be a
languishing process and make it worse
or will it make it better i think it
will make it better by clarifying that
the process that led to the settlement
agreement and the process in the
settlement agreement can go forward and
just to correct the chairman slightly
the docket the statute which was signed
into law on september 17th of 2019 told
the puc open and adjudicative proceeding
within 90 days and the commission did
exactly that it opened the proceeding in
december of 2019
i take that reference to 90 days to be a
legislative judgment that this should go
forward as expeditiously as possible it
took a long time because there are a lot
of technical issues for the uh various
stakeholders to come to agreement but
now that they have i'm a little
frustrated that it's taking the
commission so long
to um
to approve the agreement one thing you
might not know is that new hampshire has
actually been recognized as the national
leader when it comes to developing
statewide platforms like this our
friends in the state next door maine
actually adopted a statute based on ours
they told their puc to issue an rfp and
that has happened so
maine i regret to say has sort of
leapfrogged over uh new hampshire and
for that reason
not only should you pass this bill but
you should all write to the puc and say
hey puc time to issue an order
get dawn to write it
mr crease
mr greece
uh
just a clarification for me please
are you in favor of the change to
commission rather than department of
energy because that's what this bill is
doing yes i i am in favor of that change
the the department of energy is
intimately involved in this
it morphed from the staff of the puc
which was intimately involved and so i
have no shortage of faith that the doe
the department of energy will be up to
its neck in this regardless of uh what
follow up yeah
that left me kind of like
uh you
they will be involved but you would
rather have the entire process in the
hands of the commission because that's
what this bill does
yes and that means that the commission
can say settlement approved go forth and
issue your rfp
and
the at the back end of the statute the
commission gets to determine
if the costs of the platform would be
unreasonable relative to the benefits
and that authority in the commission
isn't changing didn't change as a result
of house bill 2 last year so it would
clarify that the process the path to
that approval by the puc
is still
clear and as it was originally intended
thank you
uh representative platt do you have a
question
yes yes assuming this passes
do you imagine three or four years from
now uh that the responsibility would
shift back from the puc to the
department of energy
it's possible i think you know the
platform will get up and running and
we'll see how it works and what tweaks
need to be made to the way it operates
and the way it's governed and it might
make sense
uh in three or four years to re-examine
that and
take what hopefully will be a pretty
non-controversial little bit of public
service
and vest oversight in whichever agency
representative thomas is recognized
thank you mr chairman um and uh thank
you for taking my question i apologize
for asking this question a little bit
late
but when your first words uh you you
made a statement that opened the door to
this question i'm going to ask you
when you said that the consumers
would be able to
grant a third party access to their data
could you specifically tell me
what do you mean by that what type of
data do you mean just their total
kilowatt hour usage in total or are you
talking about something that goes into
more detail
what type of data would the third party
have and be able to tell the consumer
i i'm talking about data in more detail
and the more sophisticated we get in
terms of the metering that we have our
utilities doing the more granular the
data becomes and the more uniquely
tailored to your needs at your home or
business
the data
the services can become
and so yes the answer to your question
is yes i'm talking about detailed data
and that's the reason that there are
very strong privacy protections in the
statute because this is new hampshire we
are hyper concerned as we should be
about privacy so there are protections
in the statute to make sure that that
you
your data
will not be shared your individual data
unless you grant permission
to the platform to specifically share
that data with that specific third party
provider
follow-up
thank you mr juror for the follow-up um
i'll i'll try not to use up my follow-up
question by maybe making a comment and
then ask my follow-up question i was
looking for something more specific than
just yes more detailed uh in terms of
maybe uh they
so in other words they would be able to
tell you um
when and what appliance you're using at
any one time
and my follow-up question would be
so therefore if you wanted to contact
the third party and say hey i just
bought a new
hot tub
how much
electrical power am i going to be using
based on make model year wattage and so
forth or does the consumer have to his
own math form would yield the kind of
data that would help some third party
provider
help you you can go about your business
as a lawyer or an architect or a farmer
without thinking about it all day
or if you happen to be all three of
those things then all the better
you're picking on me thank you that's
okay additional questions for
mr crease representative callie pitts
i'm sorry but i'm a little foggy this
morning
would a customer be able to access their
own data information and not have to go
through
a third party
yes
yeah and the reason i didn't stress that
is that
it's interesting and maybe informative
to you as an into your
uh consumption is but it's even better
if you can share that with a third party
thank you representative and thank you
mr crease just i'll follow on to her
comment by pointing out that i'm a
customer of new hampshire electric co-op
and the co-op offered me an opportunity
to buy a small device that i could put
into my electrical panel
and that device would track
the usage for every
appliance in the panel
and it provided a phone app that i could
use to
look at for example how much i'm using
my furnace and how much i'm using my
pump or whatever and uh it was not too
expensive maybe around 250 or so
the only thing that prevented me from
buying it was that the utility wanted
me to share that information with them
and i wasn't
comfortable with that at the time so i
did not buy it but those devices are
available
and
there is a way for customers to see
exactly what how they're using their
electricity
if i don't just let could i just respond
to that briefly before you move on to
representative
the co-op would want me to say that
you're a member of the cooperative not
just a customer meaning you own a slice
of the utility yourself along with your
fellow customers
unfortunately the co the co-op is not
part of the data platform collaboration
at present it can opt in if it wants to
that was included in the bill
uh i i i hope to i hope to entice the
cooperative to participate in the data
platform
uh but in the meantime
the the new hampshire electric co-op
because it's customer owned
has typically led the way in terms of
utility innovation and uh if you happen
to live in their territory you're lucky
as represent as chairman vos's to be a
member
representative platt i just wanted to
say i'm not interested in sharing the
hot tub because i'm usually on hot water
anyway
thank you representative plett remember
we're here to gather information and ask
questions
not provide too much information
all right thank you uh uh whoops looks
like we have one more question
yes thanks for taking my question that's
so i really get a good handle we've
we've referenced spark meters a couple
times here
uh but smart meters are not in wide uses
that usage as of yet
would a bill such as this the
information that you would gather from a
smart meter make it even more imperative
that we do have
certain um
privacy
assurances
enacted
i think the answer to your question is
yes i heard two things one it is true
that we're
not as fully deployed in smart meters as
we ought to be and so we are busy
nudging all of our utilities especially
a really big one whose name i won't
mention but whose initials are
eversource to fully implement smart
meters
uh but as your your question implies as
the meter gets smarter the privacy
implications become more profound and
that's the reason why that is a reason
why we need to be very vigilant about
privacy
okay
um any other questions for the consumer
advocate
seeing none i will thank the consumer
advocate for his testimony
great to see you here this morning
we have one more person who would like
to testify and that is kelly buchanan
who represents clean energy new
hampshire
she submitted written testimony so i
expect that her
oral testimony will be a brief summary
of that written testimony yes it will
thank you chairman and members of the
committee my name is kelly buchanan and
i am the director of legislative and
regulatory affairs for clean energy new
hampshire
i did submit
unfortunately kind of lengthy testimony
for you today so i will let you read
that on your own but um i just wanted to
come before you and let you know that we
support house bill 1285. we were a party
to the settlement agreement in the
docket that looked at establishing a
process to create this energy data
platform
and what the other uh the previous
testimony before me has said is true it
was truly a collaborative docket it's
probably the best one i've ever been a
part of to say the least and um
insofar as the commission feels any sort
of heartburn regarding this confusion in
the statute we would like to see it
resolved by using house bill 1285 as a
vehicle
and
this would ensure or help prevent any
sort of further delay with adopting the
settlement agreement in this docket
which went a great deal further
in establishing a consensus agreement on
really
quite strong privacy and security
requirements
that the utilities felt comfortable with
as well as the advocates
so i'd be happy to answer any of your
questions
i also wanted to bring before you a very
simplistic example of how the data
platform could currently be used are the
opportunities to utilize the platform
are a bit endless frankly but
say for example you're a business owner
and you're interested in having an
energy audit and some weatherization
services provided
you could contact for example one of our
members resilient buildings group here
in concord and say
oh you know i'm really interested in
having you take a look at my building
well the first thing they would do much
like when you go to the doctor you have
your blood drawn and they take a look at
how your body is functioning
is that brazilian buildings group would
go and ask the utilities to access your
energy data
as a third party service provider that
process has been really challenging um
it could take several weeks perhaps
months to get that data from the
utilities
so this data platform would really
resolve a business problem and it would
make it easier for customers to access
what is already theirs
so with that i would be happy to answer
any of your questions
thank you for that testimony any
none i'll thank you for your testimony
this morning and i will
close the public hearing on house bill
1285.
we'll take a bio break until our next
so
that they do so in a
put together that that study and i'm i'm
okay thank you uh representative notter
is recognized thank you mr chairman and
thank you for taking the question
representative wilhelm um could you
please repeat the name and the
commission you said you chaired it's the
and i'll send around this report too
it's the final report of the commission
but it's the
commission to study career pathways from
full-time service year programs to
post-secondary education and employment
opportunities in support of new
hampshire's future workforce needs it
might have more words than the number of
members of this commission that we're
proposing
but it did some effective work and
follow up mr chairman follow up i'm
holding all the
current um stats commissions
right here the list of them
have you done the math to see how much
each commission costs especially with
like 20 people when you add up mileage
staff the light bill etc
uh no do you have a number for that
okay
okay representative samsuch is
recognized
representative
i just learned something about how this
system works i tried to turn off
representative price plet's microphone
and i accidentally turned off yours so i
apologize for that
but i can't do that to you right so
as much as you might like
um yes thank you mr chairman and thank
you representative wilhelm
um
when i was still a teenager i must say i
was very much inspired by president
kennedy's peace corps
call to young people back then
and as we all know
there was a
huge boom in young people getting
involved
uh making the peace corps a
ambassador for the country in other
countries
um
however today i got to say
it seems to me that many people in this
country and i gotta say i was born in a
foreign country but many people in this
country don't seem to think that they
have any obligation to serving their
country at all
and so i want to ask you represent
wilhelm
because this is kind of i've always felt
this way that would you would you agree
with me on
the need for a concept where national
service should be something that
everyone does in this country not just
some
i thank you for the question
representative
you know i'm not for mandatory national
service
but i am for providing
uh incentives
uh to people to stand up raise their
hand folks who are inspired for whatever
reason uh to serve their community in
their country uh which is you know very
much what we were looking at with the
commission uh that wrapped up its work
last year and
uh if i might
i will say that uh the reason that i
joined americorps to serve as a civilian
national service member
[Music]
was because of the terrorist attacks on
9 11 and the call to service
by the president of the united states to
join both the military
and americorps
and i thought that that was a way that i
could serve and that's that's why i
decided to do it so i think these
opportunities are important to the
social fabric
of our country and brings diverse people
together from all different backgrounds
and walks of life from all across the
country um and i think it's important
that we do everything we can to
encourage and promote those types of
opportunities
to build national character
follow us
um well i know that your your bill
before us is for a commission and uh the
civilian core is not a mandatory issue
but considering that
it would be not too much to ask every
citizen in this country to do something
why shouldn't national service be
mandatory
it's a good question i think
you know i think we would be better for
it if we if every citizen found
something that they could do i mean that
that was president george w bush's
challenge to the country which was
everybody should take a year or two of
their lives to serve their country and
their community um so you know i believe
in figuring out where in
any any american's life they can do that
i think uh by virtue of us all being in
this room today we are we are doing that
we are serving our communities in our
country um and i think national service
representative wilhelm thank you for
your your bill
i just i'm i'm confused about a couple
the things that you
you seem to think or say that this uh
commission or this climate corps would
do
it seems to me that there are many uh
individual towns and cities
who have a very similar
type thing
not age required
and have those in action and they are
for the most part
volunteer
so
would this
type of
commission augment
what's going on locally
it seems there's momentum building
locally
would that take it away from that or
would this augment it
thank you representative for the
question uh this would augment it i
think more than anything it would uh
identify additional funding sources from
the federal government that could go to
support
programs that are happening at the state
and local level you'll see that the
municipal association is included as one
of the members in part
to make sure that all municipalities
across the state understand
opportunities
to take advantage of that kind of
funding and start programming i you know
i think about a park that is in my
neighborhood stark park
and there have been a series of rail
trails that have
been built out and connected over the
course of the last couple years by
community volunteer groups that are
doing their own fundraising
i also know that the student
conservation association that's based at
bear brook state park
which is a big supporter of this
civilian climate corps
program
they helped out in a similar effort down
in nashua to build out trails you know
serving alongside community members and
providing additional expertise
um and and a heart you know great work
ethic you know these are
these are projects that are happening in
our communities there is a there is a
backlog of projects in a lot of
communities uh and this is an additional
resource that new hampshire could take
advantage of uh if we put together a
smart strategic plan to submit it to the
federal government
follow up my follow-up would be um
that
the conservation corps that you refer to
in here
was started in the 30s after the
depression because there was no work you
put people to work and we did marvelous
things with the people i wasn't in it
but the people who did it
did marvelous work today
we have the opposite effect we have
very low unemployment
and lack of employees so how would
something like this
affect that situation because that's a
very real situation right now
it is thank you for the follow-up
i think that uh
you know a lot of the work that the
commission worked on was focused on the
future and thinking about what kind of
skills employers are looking for
i think aligning
these
these cores
these core programs national service uh
with workforce development skills so
that they can be employed
and have the skills to enter the
workforce in these high demand careers
that's that's a key part of this so
these are these are you know one
one year stints for the most part
they're between 10
10 months and 12 months
um and there are even some seasonal ones
that you know are great programs for
college students to participate in
during their summer breaks
um
and you know again the idea is for it to
be workforce development uh so that it
leads to
uh
you know good paying jobs that
you know employers are currently lacking
in the workforce
representative mcgee is recognized thank
you mr chairman and thank you
representative wilhelm for your
testimony today
i'm just looking at a section of the
bill um
i guess it's
just
section one under duties
um where there's specificity listed here
of the duties of the commission to shape
launch and sustain new hampshire's
civilian climate corps program
aimed at conserving and restoring public
lands and waters
bolstering community resilience which
is is a pet
pet
interest of mine because i think there
are a lot of things going on in terms of
changes in new hampshire
that are unaddressed because we just
don't have the resources we don't have
the you know the infrastructure in terms
of state government um
to help with those because i i actually
live on a pond a great pond and and i i
test the waters every year for the
departments you know of environmental
services water protection folks
um
so we already employ a lot of civilians
but
this section goes on to say
bolstering community resilience
increasing reforestation
increasing carbon sequestration in
agriculture the agricultural sector
protecting biodiversity
improving access to recreation and
addressing
the climate the changing climate and
what i like about the i know it's a it's
a long list but what i like about it is
from a scientific perspective you know
on this committee we listen to a lot of
bills that are energy specific in terms
of climate
but
biodiversity is another huge aspect of
what's changing
everywhere but also here
and so um
i wonder if you could just say something
about
um
the breadth of this work like this is a
volunteer core
um who are going to be examining really
complex issues in terms of what's
changing within the state
so could you could you talk a little bit
about how you see i understand the idea
of getting the state involved so you can
leverage the federal dollars that makes
total sense to me bring bring more money
to us so we can do something about the
things that are happening but
bolstering community resilience can you
tell me what you mean by that like how
would
my farming community
um
be affected if this bill went into place
and these people started to work on
coming up with you know what new
hampshire should be doing yeah thanks
for the question i mean this this list
came from recommendations by the by
america service commissions and the
service your alliance
uh they interface regularly with
americorps and
made
state level recommendations for states
i think what's important is in the
reason that they've advised creating
these
state advisory commissions
is so that every state can custom tailor
uh you know the the activities of their
core members
to focus on high need
high impact issues
that may not be
an issue that new hampshire you know of
the list on the you know the menu
may not say hey this is this is high
priority for us but again i think the
list of uh commissioners is designed uh
to figure out which of those those
issues are most important okay thank you
okay uh representative thomas is
recognized for a question
thank you mr chair
thank you for taking my question uh
first a comment i want to congratulate
you and and say i i'm i'm encouraged
when you say that
we need to get back to young people
getting a
national character established i i think
we've gotten away from that and and i
think it's encouraging that young people
are thinking that we need to establish
uh back to our roots for how how we came
to the country and why we did and get
back to that essence of having a
national character of what it is to to
be americans
um that being said um
one question i have which is in your
testimony not in the bill but um on your
second page you talk a lot about what uh
what this volunteer organization could
do
um and a lot of it seems like it's it
may already be done by
for profit industries here in the state
so my question would be
do you see a conflict in what this what
this agency that you want to form
would do in terms of how it would affect
our for-profit businesses that are
already doing a lot of these things that
are being done now and how that blend
together how that makes
great i thank you for the question uh i
think it's important uh that you know
that it is in federal statute that
national service members cannot displace
employees
that are already doing this work and
that's across the private public and
non-profit sectors so
uh
you know to be in compliance with
federal law
it's going to be important for this
commission
to look at
needs that are not being met by private
industry uh by
you know the state and by uh nonprofit
organizations but that are maybe on the
wish list of things that they they would
really like to be able to get to uh and
again look at it through a workforce
development lens uh so that you know
they're putting these core members in
positions where they can uh build the
skills that they need to then go on and
work for those
for-profit companies or for the state
you know or for non-profit organizations
follow up
thank you miss chair for the follow-up
and uh
this might be a naive question but do
you see this organization being
volunteer
and we have many volunteer organizations
in the state do you see this volunteer
organization
becoming or is it intent to become
a type of a lobbying group
no so that's another thing that you
should know about americorps and
civilian national services
when uh the corporation for national and
community service the federal agency
that oversees these programs was created
uh it was put into statute a couple
things i mean i'm actually thinking of a
long list of things that might be
helpful for this group to know one it's
intentionally bipartisan the the board
of directors of the federal agency um
are appointed by both majority minority
parties in washington d.c
so that there is that bipartisan
support for the programs and guidance um
sorry can you get back to what what your
question oh it's about lobbying and no
and so that's that's something that is
strictly prohibited by americorps
members i mean otherwise
you know there'd be a room full of
americorps members and say yes we want
to expand these programs
um but that's that's not the case so i
appreciate the question and know that
there are safeguards in place to
okay before we ask more questions i just
want to
point out that
representative mcgee
you came in a little late so you didn't
hear our
opening
discussion but one of the things we
talked about was that we're here for
information gathering and if you
ask
crisp succinct questions you'll gather
more information
than if you ask long rambling questions
so i just uh ask you to be mindful of
that
i have a couple of questions for you as
well
mr chairman
yes can i just say i so i have another
bill hearing at 11 15.
um i'm happy to come back later if
that's helpful i'm also happy to give
them a heads up that i'm running late or
maybe we could ask someone to
go let them know that i'm running late
here well that clock is five minutes
fast oh that's perfect uh it's only
1107.
um how far away do you have to go to
tesla go down one floor just down one
floor okay let me just ask you a couple
of quick questions then
um
your testimony mentioned climate corps
pilots across the country where do these
pilots get their funding
they're currently funded by americorps
uh in part but they also leverage those
federal dollars with local investment
um
so there's there's a federal match
requirement
part of the brilliance of the modern
national service movement is that there
is
a public
private match requirement um when i was
serving with city or new hampshire we
were based out of timberland's corporate
headquarters in stratham
and that contributed towards the
program's match requirement
so
as a follow-up if there were any of
these climate corps
pilots started in new hampshire the
funding source would be americorps is
that correct that's correct so student
conservation corps is a great example of
that it's the
uh and there's also a lakes region uh
conservation corps as well
that does similar work i think on a
seasonal basis
okay representative wilhelm i want to
really thank you for your testimony
thanks for introducing this bill and all
the hard work you've put into it i'll
let you go so you can go testify on your
other bill
and
just thank you again look forward to
talking to you again great thank you
chairman thank you members of the
committee we currently have no more pink
cards that have been submitted by people
to testify on this bill are there any
is there anyone else who would like to
testify
no
oh okay just going to turn off the
microphone all right
um
well seeing none i guess
we will end the public hearing on house
bill 1419a
as introduced
and
i had originally planned a relatively
long lunch break from 11 30 to
1 o'clock but it looks like we're going
to get an even longer one so
everybody enjoy your lunch and we'll see
you back here at one o'clock and i will
you